moving on
our main story tonight concerns guns you
know big pew pew sticks that go boom
boom
guns are everywhere in america and i do
mean everywhere
how many guns you think i can hide
underneath a hawaiian shirt
of course we got the gray man got my
beretta model 85 feels like a car arm
ct45 charter arms undercover
38 special grandpa dave's old derringer
this is a sky
cpx2 smith and wesson 442 oh wait
one more north american arms
sidewinder 22 magnum just in case you
need something small
wow that is the second most horrifying
thing you can find coming at you in a
hawaiian shirt right after
john lasseter on national hug your boss
day although i will say
the reveal of the thumbelina sized gun
in his tommy bahama pocket was an
m night shyamalan worthy twist well done
tiny gun you are both superfluous and
surprising but this story isn't so much
about guns themselves
as it is about one particular law that
significantly expanded how they're used
i'm talking about
stand your ground laws 30 states
currently have them and while they were
initially pitched as a law and order
measure to protect people forced to make
difficult decisions in impossible
life or death situations in practice
they can be evoked in incidents that
really seem like they didn't need to
turn deadly
the man who shot and killed a father of
four at a fluorescent bar is free
tonight
so far the gunman's not facing charges
for the shooting at show me's bar and
grill on wednesday afternoon
the saint louis county prosecutor says
he needs more time to decide whether
he'll prosecute the gunman
that's because missouri's stand your
ground law is complicated scott berry
was killed when an argument over
how heavy a dog could weigh became
physical
holy not only is that a massive
overreaction it's a pointless argument
everyone knows dogs come in a wide array
of sizes from pocket-sized sweeties to
slender kings
to dense boys to droopy boys to big
honking boys
to standard that's just veterinary
science
stand your ground laws gained notoriety
nearly a decade ago when police claimed
that florida's law
kept them from initially arresting
george zimmerman after he shot and
killed 17 year old trayvon martin
more recently they've been floated as a
potential defense for the killers of a
mart arbory and those
are just two devastating examples of
many and don't worry
we're not going to show you the far too
plentiful footage of people getting shot
in public places tonight
frankly we're just one senseless murder
away from hbo max putting this show in
the endless parade of human misery
category alongside chernobyl
and entourage but given the prevalence
of stand your ground laws and the racial
disparities in who they do
and crucially don't protect we thought
tonight it'd be worth taking a look at
them and let's start
with why exactly stand your ground laws
were created
because before they came along most
states already had
self-defense laws on the books that
traditionally included an
element known as a duty to retreat
meaning
you couldn't resort to using deadly
force in the confrontation if
you could safely avoid or de-escalate it
now
in many states an exception to this rule
was a so-called
castle doctrine a legal theory arguing
that your home is your castle and there
you can use deadly force much more
broadly to protect yourself against
intruders
the key thing stand your ground laws did
was remove that
duty to retreat from public places
basically
extending the castle doctrine to
anywhere you have a legal right to be
if you have a reasonable fear someone
might hurt you you have just as much
right to shoot them in the street
as you would if they were coming through
the window of your house and this change
was largely thanks to the advocacy of
one woman with a pretty compelling story
marion hammer says she was walking to
her car after a long day at the office
when she was accosted by a car full of
men
but she had a surprise for them
i drew the gun up through the headlights
of the car
and i aimed at the driver and somebody
in the car
screamed the got a gun
the got a gun i honestly did not
expect to hear that
come out of that woman's mouth help
yourself to some hard candies in the
ceramic pig
absolutely take off your boots so you
don't track anything on the wall-to-wall
carpeting
of course but a curse word in the
daylight not in 10
000 contractions of the universe but the
important part of her story concerns
what she claims a police chief said to
her
after she told her story publicly the
police chief told
me well in that situation if you'd
called the police
we'd have arrested you because you were
the only one
who employed the use of deadly force
and that made me angry and that argument
is the absolute core of the case for
standing ground laws that marion hammer
could have been arrested for simply
defending herself now she wasn't of
course
that didn't happen but someone said that
she might have been and that
made her angry put a few things there
because
while everything about marion hammer
seems like a sweet everyday grandmother
right down to this feline glamour shot
of her posted on a cat breeder's website
you should know she's also one of the
country's most powerful gun lobbyists
and
a former president of the nra she has
personally helped push through dozens of
gun laws in florida alone including
a 1987 bill allowing conceal and carry
permits
a law then duplicated in some form in
almost every state
leading to more than 16 million
americans currently having licenses to
carry concealed handguns so
that margaritaville arsenal that you saw
earlier you have this dana carvey
character
to thank for that situation and while
it's not entirely relevant you should
know
hammer's advocacy wasn't limited just to
guns
she also successfully killed a petition
from ten thousand school children
to change the florida state bird to the
scrub jay
a bird so friendly it apparently eats
peanuts out of your hand now she
objected because in her words
begging for food isn't sweet it's lazy
and it's a welfare mentality and
they eat the eggs of other birds that's
robbery and murder
i don't think scrub jays can even sing
and okay
slow down there marion set aside lazy
welfare mentality and robbery and murder
which is a lot to put on a bird scrub
jays can't sing
you might want to tell that to the scrub
jay marion
see that's fine is it great no it's not
great it's fine it's
perfectly fine sure the bird is no
mariah but it's also no roseanne if that
bird is anyone
it's fergie you heard me the scrub jay
is fergie tweet it
talk it put it in your pocket i've made
a flimsy take and i'm proud of it the
point is
marin hammer played a big part in
passing one of the country's first
standing ground laws in florida and
the passage of that bill was immensely
useful to the nra because
it became a model for laws that they
could then push around the country
wayne lapierre openly said at the time
that florida was the first step of a
multi-state strategy
and they were going to use the tailwind
to move from state legislature to state
legislature
and they did just six years later
standing ground laws had passed in 22
states
and while following the killing of
trayvon martin they became increasingly
controversial
states did not stop passing the laws
they just slightly slowed down
and dennis baxley one of the state
representatives who helped draft
florida's bill was
adamant that it should not be rolled
back we should stand beside law abiding
citizens
they should not be treated as a criminal
they're doing something positive which
is stopping a violent act from occurring
there are going to be times with close
calls near the foul line
is it in or is it out who's the
assailant and who's the victim
yeah there are going to be some close
calls is it in or is it out
is it right or is it wrong is it
self-defense or is it a murder provoked
by debate about how much a dog can weigh
that turned physical who can say
not that guy and that is a little bit of
the point here
the way most states stand your ground
floors are constructed they can make
determining questions of guilt
incredibly difficult because it all
comes down to perceived fear
whether you legitimately saw someone as
a threat and that
is definitionally subjective what i am
afraid of
snakes clowns and tilda swinton jesus
christ might not be what you are
and it's made even harder by the fact
that often the only other person who
knows what happened in the incident
is now dead and citing stand your ground
as a legal defense has been extremely
successful
in florida alone as of 2012 nearly 70
percent
of people who claimed it as a defense
had gone free and
advocates for these laws will tell you
that that's a good thing that
before their introduction good people
were getting sent to jail
all of the time simply for defending
themselves but they
never had much in the way of actual
evidence for that
beyond hypotheticals like marion
hammer's story about how someone said
she could have gone to jail but
crucially
she didn't so standing ground laws
weren't really fixing a problem
that needed solving and the dangers they
posed were pretty obvious to some from
the start
when georgia was debating a standing
ground law in 2006
a local station asked people in the
streets what they thought and watch
as their third interviewee realizes
something that the first two don't
i think it's a lower crime myself
because if a person is going to think
twice about running up on a citizen
if he thinks that citizens armed if you
feel your life's in danger i think i
think it's a
good law i think it's going to get a lot
of people hurt why is that well
because when you walk up to me in the
parking lot i didn't know who you were
and by this loud
if i felt that you threatened me i could
just shot you right now
you know that i can't that's not right
yeah that last guy is completely right
and in hindsight
maybe we shouldn't have listened to the
man in the pride of the south hat
that by the way features a portrait of
robert e lee over a confederate flag
that hat alone should have immediately
disqualified anything he said
it's like if anthony fauci wore this
bucket hat that says daddy in the shrek
font
if he did you'd be duty bound to ignore
anything that he
said because the fact is we now know
overall
not only do stand your ground laws not
deter crime they may actually
increase violence in standing ground
states homicides overall have
increased nearly 11 percent since the
law's enactment whereas
in states without those laws the
homicide rate went down
by just over two percent in fact another
study found such laws translate into an
additional
600 homicides per year and if you think
it will come on
you can't draw a straight line between
these specific laws
and people's actions in some cases you
very much
can including one of the very first
standing ground cases in texas
that of joe horn who called 9-1-1 to
report a burglary happening during the
day
at his next-door neighbor's house i've
got a shotgun
uh do you want me to stop him nope don't
do that
ain't no property worth shooting
somebody over okay joe horn sounds
clearly upset am i gonna let him get
away with it i can't take a chance on
getting killed over this okay
no i'm gonna shoot i'm gonna shoot but
the 9-1-1 dispatcher warns horn to stay
inside at least
a dozen separate times i've got officers
coming out there
i don't want you to go outside that
house then horn sounding angrier by the
moment
cites the new texas law that i have a
right to protect myself too sir and you
understand that
and the laws have been changed in this
country and since september the first
and you know it and i know it
yeah joe horn knew what the law said and
despite the dispatcher warning him not
to go outside 14 times
he did just that and killed two people
with autopsy reports later showing that
both men appear to have been shot in the
back
he was explicitly told that property is
not worth shooting people over
which is obviously true and certainly
not your neighbor's property
if i found out my neighbor shot and
killed two people to save my ps5
i would move tomorrow i know they're
hard to get your hands on but jesus
christ calm down
i don't want your blood console and
thanks to texas's new standing ground
laws
joe horn was never arrested and
ultimately
a grand jury declined to ever charge him
with a crime and not only
was horn spared any consequences he was
later celebrated as a hero
yeah 9-1-1 on and you said i'm going to
go stop them
this you got to get here i'm going to
stop them they said
no no no don't go out you you stopped
them they came towards you you shot them
yes sir that's right correct and
okay set aside that joe horn looks like
what would happen if bobby hill grew up
and
sucked the only time it's appropriate to
cheer after someone says you shot them
is if you're talking about the
individual responsible for shooting this
video of a family of bears in a swimming
pool
question you saw the bears you had your
phone ready and you shot them right
answer yes sir that's correct cue the
applause
no other circumstances none and if these
laws on their own weren't bad enough
there is now also a small cottage
industry
that's cropped up around them selling
specialized self-defense legal
assistance
most of these companies offer membership
packages including everything from
educational training videos
to money for future legal defense and
bond the u.s concealed carry association
insists it's primarily concerned with
teaching conflict avoidance but
it also gives you a wallet-sized card
with tips on how to handle the call you
make to police
after you've shot someone a handy
feature that their founder
proudly touts to its members this is my
own very own usca card you can see my
name on it tim schmidt
on the back of the card actually lists
the exact instructions on what to say to
a responding officer explain
i was attacked feared for my life and i
had to defend myself
okay setting aside the fact that looks
like the most boring episode of
sportscenter imaginable it does feel
important to point out
that they've essentially created a get
out of jail free card and that
mixed with that man's get out of jail
free complexion is a pretty awful
combination
and at least one of uscca's clients
apparently took the advice
on that card and ran with it carlos
garcia's ex-wife jailene ayala paints
him as a loving father who would do
anything for his children she believes
he was intoxicated when he showed up to
pick up his kids
and got into an argument with the next
door neighbor nick julian iv
over him playing loud music in the car
julian armed himself with a handgun
and shot garcia he claims in
self-defense
neighbors came out as julian iv was on
with 9-1-1
what is your emergency yes ma'am i just
had a man attack me in my front yard
he attacked me and i had to use force
i was afraid for my life yeah it seems
all you have to do is memorize a few key
phrases
and you too could be free to shoot with
impunity it's basically rosetta stone
for justified homicides
because during his 9-1-1 call nick
julian made sure to say he feared for
his life
three separate times and can also be
heard referring to his wallet and saying
to someone
you just need to call them give them the
account number and my attorney and by
the time the police arrived
he was already on the phone with the us
concealed carry association setting up
his legal defense
before his victim had even been declared
dead
and i know it might seem like these laws
are just a free-for-all to shoot someone
who scares you but the truth is
there are some limits and you probably
know where this is going
because while most civilian shootings
involve people of the same race
when cases involve shootings across
racial lines
there are significant disparities in
whose fear gets believed
because the odds a white on black
homicide was deemed justified by the
police
were 281 percent greater than the odds a
white on white homicide was
and the expansion of stand your ground
laws have appeared to worsen that
disparity a fact
i'm pretty sure would surprise exactly
two of these three men
not only that but there are multiple
examples where you would think
if ever a stand your ground law would
apply
this would be the case and yet it didn't
take sawatu salamara who waved an
unloaded registered gun at a woman she
believed was trying to hit her and her
young daughter with her car
but even though her state of michigan
has a stand your ground law
and even though that incident clearly
falls under a reasonable definition of
self-defense without it and even
though she didn't even shoot the gun
because again it was unloaded
she was sentenced to two years on the
charge of using a gun to commit a felony
and while after outcry she was
eventually able to plead to a lesser
charge
that wasn't before she'd spent a year in
prison and she was pregnant at the time
and was forced to give birth in shackles
so
despite being introduced to increase
safety
stand your ground laws actually increase
violence and
given around four centuries of history
basing a law around
who's afraid of who was always going to
be dangerous
it's the reason ohio state legislator
stephanie house stood up to oppose her
state passing its standing ground law
back in 2018 when your presence
when you're being your blackness
causes fear do you hear what i'm saying
i've been in these these floors where i
hear people tell me
you know people scared of you
it's people i have never interacted with
what do you do in places and spaces when
your
presence literally your face
your face causes someone to be fearful
of you
this is a bad idea for people that look
like me exactly that is just
one of the things that makes these laws
so dangerous they can exalt a white
person's fear
over a black person's life and are
replied so unevenly the sewato salamara
gave birth in shackles while this guy
gets a parade
standing ground laws have contributed to
a society where vigilantes with guns
feel they have the right to decide what
is safety who is a threat
and what the punishment should be they
have turbocharged
everything from road rage incidents to
pointless disputes over dog weights
so what can we do well the answer is
actually pretty simple
don't pass any more stand your ground
laws and
repeal the ones that exist they're
redundant solutions
to a made-up problem and they are
actively doing harm
in the past year at least 14 bills have
been introduced in five states
to roll their stand your ground laws
back and if you live in a
stand-your-ground state
especially one where those bills have
been introduced
you should absolutely write to your
representatives
to urge them to repeal them as soon as
possible
and while you're at it if you do live in
florida or you know what it
any state in the interest of annoying
marion hammer why not also demand that
they make your state bird the florida
scrub jay so that it can maybe one day
deliver its fergalicious victory song
that's a b-plus bird that bird is fine
that's our show thanks so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night
you